hey youtubers it's Charlie so yesterday
during my Game of Thrones religions
video I asked you all to submit
questions so now I'll try and figure out
what everyone's thinking about what's
really going on with the gods I know the
Emmys were last night - and you guys
felt like they got the shaft a little
game of Thrones did win a lot of
technical Emmys so we could feel happy
about that but I'll also announce who
won the book giveaway whenever we get
through everything and if you're just
finding me for the first time I do a
weekly Game of Thrones book giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment whenever
I post a bonus video so general spoilers
for everything through season 4 but here
we go
question number one shadow wolf asks do
the Dragons have gods so I think of the
Dragons as being more like highly
evolved animals they're like really
intuitive flying lizards I think that
they just operate on primal instinct but
they are connected to the balance of
nature in a way that hasn't been fully
explained I think it's more likely that
people would have worshipped them in a
general sense dragons were too Valerians
what horses are - Dothraki they're part
of the culture and highly respected you
could argue that they serve the old gods
or the god of nature or have you want to
think about it
but serving and worshipping are two
completely different things I think
dragons are connected to fire magic
rollers presented as Lord of Light so
you could link them to him - then
there's the Daenerys Zora hi theories
which I've talked about in my other
Theory video so if I had to pick I would
say they exist on the side of the red
god or the old gods but I don't think
it's going to be that simple
just explain how they're connected to
fire magic or the seasons or the balance
of the seasons essentially whenever
dragons started to proliferate the world
started to get hotter like the climate
started increase and as they started to
die off the climate started to get
colder thus dragons have a certain
connection to the balance of the seasons
but question number 2 rainbow fish
bubbles asks do you think that the
children of the forest might someday
serve the great other or will the
children make the White Walkers bow down
to them and their gods so the children
were involved in stopping the forces of
the great other after the long night or
the end of the long night so it's
implied that they have a more neutral
position it was implied that a peace
treaty was brokered to end the long
night and they were involved in sealing
that pact I think it's more likely that
they'll just serve nature and depending
on which way the balance tips they'll
serve one side or the other
the children do seem to have some sort
of weird relationship with the
three-eyed raven and it's implied that
he might be
in service of the great other but I
don't necessarily think that that means
that the children are in service of the
great other and even if that's true
that's all just rumors and theories
though I mean if priests of the red God
can disagree with each other then so can
the green seers the three-eyed Raven is
the last green seer that is until Brandt
came to learn from him so even if the
children are working on the opposing
side of the red God it doesn't mean
they're surrendering or bowing down it
would probably only be in service of the
natural order of things for example if
the Dragons started to overpopulate in
the climate of the world heated up so
much that everything turned into a
desert the children would probably try
to restore balance by serving the great
other on to question number three applix
asks who did the Valyrians worship so
they actually worshiped a variety of
deities there wasn't any main one God
the Valyrian freehold was created after
the Valyrian tame dragons and used them
to conquer the Eastern continent so just
like the Greeks of Romans you ended up
with a wide variety of citizens from
conquered nations with all of their own
gods beyond that we don't know if the
Valerians had any kind of organized
religion before they tamed dragons and
conquered the Eastern continent because
they lived in this area near slavers Bay
in the summer sea you could tie them to
a lot of the local religions that are
practiced in Mereen nowadays I'm not an
expert on the evolution of religion but
most early religion relates mostly to
burial rites like the way the religion
of the old gods doesn't have a lot of
complex customs george RR martin has
teased that we will see glimpses of old
Valyria pre doom in winds of winter and
cream of spring though right now the
only people in the series that have
claimed to actually travel there is your
on Greyjoy which seems like the show is
gonna be cutting him out and Tywin
Lannister's younger brother Jerry and
Lannister he travelled to validity to
try and recover bright roar that was the
lost Valyrian blade of house lannister
but he never returned he's actually like
a whole other interesting character who
was like a really good friend to Tyrion
as a child I don't think the show's
gonna do that character either but
Tyrion could totally run into him again
in the books but on to question number
four edward fall asks what do you think
is gonna happen at the end of the series
Wow as spoilery is this answer could get
I did I like a white Walker prophecy
video and you can just watch that I get
into like really great details about you
know how the balance might be restored
with the brokering of a truce and a
peace treaty
so I going to break the tail end of that
I'll add a link in the description think
about it this way though it's all about
maintaining the balance of nature
so a lot of allegiances in the show will
probably shift around and people that
you think are heroes will probably end
up being villains question number five
johanna adams asks can we would trees be
grown or transplanted probably not
transplanted but they can certainly be
grown like you could take seeds and
plant new trees I don't think that
they're like the ents from Lord of the
Rings though the trees are connected to
a certain type of nature magic but
they're not just gonna pick up and start
running around I'm really hoping that we
learn more about them in season five of
the show but we'll definitely learn more
about them in winds of winter question
number six Brian Navarro asks does the
great other have sleeper cells around
the world and do other people besides
the White Walkers worship Him so it
depends on how you view him is he like
an evil god or see like a God of nature
there could be people in the north that
say prayers to him in terms of sleeper
cells no I don't think it's gonna work
that way I think it's gonna be more like
during Aegon's conquest Icahn allowed
people to surrender or join his army
obviously the White Walkers aren't gonna
let people join their army they're gonna
turn them into whites think about it
this way they start with their forces in
the lands of always winter then as they
push south they slowly kill people and
turn them into whites making the army
stronger since we saw the white Walker
March right past Samwell at the end of
season two is possible that they could
leave people alone if they don't
perceive them to be threats the further
south that they push the larger their
army will grow at a certain point I
think we'll see people try and serve the
true balance of nature and if the forces
of the red God are doing something to
thwart that people could take action
against them but it doesn't mean that
they're gonna be serving the white
walkers are the great other another
really simple way to think about it is
the enemy of my enemy is my friend so
you can see characters switch sides
based on those principles question
number seven Tomoe asks who's storyline
are they gonna cut out in season five
it's not so much about them cutting
storylines out it's about them cutting
characters out and giving those
characters stories to other characters
for example we haven't heard about the
Greyjoy uncle's being cast those people
do a few pretty important things in book
four so it's possible they could give
those parts of the story - Theon Sister
Yara her name in the books is different
than that on the show but you get the
idea they did the same thing with Gendry
in season three they gave heed ryx
storm's story from Storm of Swords to
him and then they give Gendry story arts
some of it to hot pie the big parts of
the story stayed pretty close to the
books the biggest changes that you
really notice are the
characters themselves like characters
show up in places that they didn't show
up in the books but question number
eight VOD asks if you had to choose a
religion which one would you pick
I do like me some resurrection but I
probably pick the old gods just because
it seems like the simplest I wouldn't
have to sit through like long boring
rituals or Church sermons like in the
faith of the seven I don't know about
you guys but it feels like a lot of
times in the books people's religions
just have a lot to do with their
personalities like Arielle worships
death because she's so hardcore now but
before that she worship the old gods
just like our family I feel like my
personality changes a lot over time just
as much as characters in the story so I
feel like I might say something
different in a couple years but for
right now I'll just say old gods just to
keep it simple question number nine
virus asks where is the blackfish where
has he been hiding since the red wedding
this is actually the rare case where
after the red wedding the books in the
show do pretty much the same thing but
then there's a bit of a divergence he
ended up escaping the red wedding
Massacre because he was outside the
castle whenever went down he ran
back to Riverrun and he's been holed up
there since then if you remember
Riverrun sits on a small piece of land
in a body of water so whenever he pulls
the drawbridge up the castle can only be
reached by boat so they can't just March
an army right up to the gates the show
is basically cutting out the Riverrun
part of the story that we see from book
4 so if you have read book 4 they're not
gonna do River Run at all or it doesn't
seem like they are the blackfish does
have a pretty interesting story in book
4 but I suppose they could always come
back to him at a future point either way
he's still alive in the books and on the
show he's just on the run and question
number 10 last one
Nicole ma asks do people get rez
sickness when they get brought back to
life reduced stats suck I actually
laughed at this a little bit because I
used to be totally addicted to Warcraft
but yes there is a little bit of rez
sickness beric Dondarrion on the show
said that each time roller brought him
back from the dead it felt like a little
piece of him got left behind so
presumably there is a limit to the
number of times someone can be brought
back and when you do get brought back
you are slightly lesser than you were
before so you do have slightly reduced
stats so far the known limit to
Resurrection is Lady Stoneheart like
she's the furthest gone we've seen a
person beat and come back I think she
was special just because of the
circumstances of her death and the will
of her mind so I don't think that she's
like an absolute limit I think she's a
special case but
that answer some of you guys big
questions thank you so much for
submitting I'm always loved doing these
videos my next bonus video is gonna be
about the civil war between the faith
militant and the crown that happened
like a long time before events on the
show I'll try and post that on next
Sunday and congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Marcus Gaskins
you and your choice of any of martin's
books you want Kindle or paperback I'll
message you on your channel for details
remember all you guys have to do to
enter the giveaway or enter for
consideration is be a subscriber and
just leave a comment whenever I post
bonus videos but there's a whole lot of
stuff happening this week and I'll be
posting updates on Twitter and Facebook
so if you want to follow me there I'll
have links for that at the bottom of the
description but in the meantime as
promised you can click here to learn all
about that white Walker prophecy if you
never saw that video that I posted and
you can click here to learn all about
the faceless men thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you